welcome to the man of Recaps this is
Marvel's secret Invasion we begin with
our favorite CIA guy Everett Ross who's
getting a report from an agent about a
crazy conspiracy theory of
shape-shifting aliens I don't know buddy
that sounds pretty far-fetched but turns
out agent Ross is one of them how many
people have been replaced by Scrolls
remember it wasn't Captain Marvel back
in the 90s when a young Nick Fury first
encountered the shape-shifting Scrolls
but they turned out to be good aliens
who are refugees just trying to live
peacefully and fury befriended them in
fact ever since the end credits of
Spider-Man far from home Nick Fury has
been working with them on a space
station that we now know is called saber
but with the secret Invasion going on
now Nick Fury comes back to Earth he
meets up with his best human friend
agent Maria Hill and his best alien
friend the scroll leader Talos now Fury
had promised he would help find the
Scrolls another planet to live on but
Talus breaks the bad news uh the scrolls
are sick awaiting they voted him out and
voted in a new leader gravic whose plan
is to kill all humans and take Earth as
their home apparently skrulls are immune
to radiation so graphic's plan is to
impersonate humans and incite nuclear
war so humans will extinct themselves
and the Scrolls can in peace in the
nuclear Wasteland indeed Graphics living
at a radioactive power plant in Russia
where he's got like a bunch of Scrolls
living happily but also mostly there are
terrorist organization that's body
snatching humans and then keeping them
in their brain pods one of his top
lieutenants is a young woman oh snap
it's Khaleesi she's transporting a bomb
when Talos catches up to her but turns
out this is talos's daughter Gaia she's
a True Believer in graphics cause until
her Dad Reveals it was gravic who killed
her mother so now she realizes she's
been working for the bad guy she helps
them try to stop the bomb plot but it's
hard to Trail graphic when he's a
shapeshifter and by the time Fury
catches up to him it's too late boom
blows up the Russian festival and on the
way out he shifts into Fury and shoots
Maria Hill yes this is not to fake out
ancient Maria Hill dies the Scrolls
framed the Americans so it's going to
start world war three but luckily one of
the advisors to the president is our
friend the war machine Colonel James
Rhodes Fury's like hey man scroll secret
Invasion but roady's like I don't know
bud that sounds pretty far-fetched and
with the video footage that Fury was
there and shot Maria Hill it's like
sorry man you're disavowed you're fired
so Fury goes home to to his nice little
house but there's a scroll in the
kitchen cooking dinner oh snap they're
married Nick Fury has a secret scroll
wife yeah since the 90s Nick Fury has
been working with Talos in a small group
of Scrolls as his own personal secret
shape-shifting spy group one of them was
this girl woman Vara and you know how it
goes they fell in love but their
marriage isn't in a great place right
now because she thought he was dead for
five years when he disappeared in the
snap and as soon as he came back he ran
off to a space station so she's feeling
a bit abandoned and now she gets a visit
from Roadie who turns out has been
replaced by a scroll graphic monster to
kill Fury and so they have a tense
breakfast Mr and Mrs Smith both shoot
each other but yeah they both missed on
purpose so that's a good sign they're
still in love so Fury's gotta stop
graphic's Next plan to have the British
shoot down a plane Gaia still undercover
goes into this guy's brain to get his
abort password and they stop it just in
time but graphic suspected he had a
traitor now he knows it's her and shoots
her but earlier she discovered graphic
secret project where he's got the DNA of
a bunch of super people because scrolls
are so adaptable they could take these
powers and graphic wants to make himself
a super scroll so guys in there and
Infused herself with the extremists
remember from Iron Man 3 that yes gives
you healing powers and she's all right
so is the president's going for peace
talks graphic scrolls are posing as
Russians and try to assassinate the
president it's up to Fury and Talus to
save the president but oh Talos gets
shot which makes him start turn and
scroll Fury tells everyone he's on their
side and they get the president out of
there but now the guy helping Talos was
graphic in Disguise and he finishes the
job and again it's not to fake out Talos
dies with the scroll secret out of the
bag fake Roadie has to shift gears and
tell the president the scrolls are
working with the Russians so we gotta
bomb him Fury figures out to this road
he's an imposter but he can't really do
much about it at the moment so Fury gets
help from his British spy friend Sonja
falsworth she's a hilarious character
who's been hunting Scrolls herself and
being very British and quippy now
graphic only has some super DNA mostly
he uses the Groot arm what he really
wants is the Harvest the secret blood
samples that Fury took after the battle
in end game which includes just every
Super person in the MCU so Fury suits up
for the final battle he pulls his trench
coat out of one Locker then his eye
patch out of another then a single
pistol out of another I don't want to
tell him his business but it seems like
those could have all fit in one so Fury
busted into Graphics compound although
remember it's irradiated so he's dying
but fear he's like hey I brought you the
Harvest if I give you this will you go
conquer some other planet and leave
Earth alone that's kind of a weird plan
especially because graphic can just take
the powers and Conquer Earth anyway he
fires it up with Fury still in there
because he's not to scroll it wouldn't
work on him and now buff gravic is
Captain America going in to kill Fury
but oh what's this yeah Fury did get the
powers too because that's not the real
Fury surprise it's Gaia now it's time
for the super scroll fight and all they
both got the powers of all the Avengers
uh they can only like turn their arms
one at a time I guess to use each power
so it's a big punch out with lots of
Hulk arms but they both got Captain
Marvel Powers which are maybe the
strongest of all and lets them fly and
in the end it's Gaia who gets gravic and
blam kills King Piccolo with the
Kamehameha she rescues all the humans
from the brain pods including agent Ross
and the real Roadie who apparently has
been down there for a while very
meanwhile has spent this whole time I'm
trying to convince the president that
this road is a scroll finally though he
just shoots him which yeah would have
been the fastest way to prove it so the
president stops the nuclear launch and
the day is saved except this ends up
causing more problems because the
president missed the distinction between
the good Scrolls and bad Scrolls he just
tells everyone the scrolls are invading
and they're all evil this sets off a
wave of violence as people just start
shooting anyone they think might be a
scroll Sonya fallsworth at least
understands there are good Scrolls and
she teams up with Gaia to figure stuff
out in fact they find another secret
brainpod lair but we don't get explained
uh whose this is as for Nick Fury he
feels his job is done here so he's going
back to space but this time his wife
Vara is gonna come with and they fly off
to live happily ever after so that's
where secret Invasion comes to an end if
you like this recap hit that subscribe
button for more of the best Recaps of TV
and movies
foreign